Hello everybody!
Hello!
How are you?
I'm good, and you?
I'm good, yeah!
So today is...
English and Japanese language among us.
And I'm looking forward to the games with everybody.
And... yeah!
Thank you everyone for coming!
Good morning!
Today's collaboration has a lot of people, right?
14 people, 14 members.
Yeah!
So we will be using English and Japanese.
In today's stream, among us.
English and Japanese.
Let's start with self-introduction!
Yes!
Okay...
Hello!
I'm Kaheru!
I am Kaheru, I live inside a trash bin.
I am 666 years old.
My Japanese is not good.
But I will do my best!
Let's have fun today!
Let's have fun!
Hi!
Nice to meet you.
My name is Mint Phantom.
I will do my best in Japanese today.
I will do my best.
Let's have fun!
Thank you!
Nice to meet you!
Hello!
Hi!
My name is Milky Queen.
I am a rice idol and Vtuber.
Hi!
My name is Milky Queen, rice idol.
Lovely to meet you all.
Thank you!
Woah!
Yo!
Hello!
My name is Miyuri.
I am an adventurer.
Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you!
Everyone introduced themselves in English and Japanese.
I feel so dumb.
Okay, I'll just introduce myself.
Okay!
Since my main language is Indonesian, I'll just use my main...
We are on fire!
Nice to meet you.
Hello!
I am Pia Medaleo from Chiki Team 48 Virtual.
Nice to meet you!
Good evening, everyone!
I am Shiki Miyoshino, the occult Okinogami to make you happy to be alive, whether that's through scares or songs.
Sorry, my Japanese is terrible.
Please take care of me!
I'll do my best!
You are good!
Good, good.
How do you say good in English?
Good!
Good Japanese!
Patient English.
Hi!
Good evening!
I am Ayami, an illustrator and Vtuber.
I am 100 years old illustrator and Vtuber Ayami.
And Ayami is Mint Mama.
Thank you!
Today, my goal is to kill Mint.
Please take care of me!
I am Etra from Ogiri High School.
Everyone is mixing English and Japanese, so I can't speak at all.
Please take care of me!
I can't speak at all.
It's okay.
Me too.
I can't speak Japanese at all.
You are speaking!
Hello Koyo!
Oha Koyo!
It's Koyo here from Kemono Friends V Project.
I'm Koyote from Kemono Friends V Project.
Thank you everybody for coming to the collab.
And I'm very happy that we're gonna...
I can't speak English.
Koyo!
It's Koyo!
Thank you!
Hi!
I'm Chune from Kemono Friends V Project.
I can't speak English, but my passion is English.
I am fighting!
Fighting!
Please take care of me!
Is it okay?
Yes.
Good evening!
I'm Marunanamuna from Sony Music V.
Oh, I turned it upside down.
Everyone, good evening!
I'm Marunanamuna from Sony Music V.
I'll try not to kill people, but maybe...
Maybe?
You never know.
Kill!
Please take care of me!
Good morning!
I'm Rikumu from Yume Kaito.
I really don't understand English.
I can't speak English.
OK?
OK!
Good!
Thank you!
I'll do my best!
The end Good evening!
I'm Rurururika from .love.
Ruru's English is... Why are you laughing?
You're cute!
Thank you!
Um... What was it?
What was it?
You said Rurururika.
If you speak English slowly, I can understand a little.
But I can't speak it, so I'll do my best with my passion.
Do your best with your passion!
Passion English!
With passion!
Thank you!
Yaho!
I'm Nekomiya Hinata.
Ah, um...
Ah, that's right.
Um, what was it?
Nekomiya Hinata.
Uninfected, Among Us, Ponkotsu.
OK?
OK!
Me too, me too.
Yes, that's all.
Everyone, please take care of me.
Please take care of me.
Ah, I'm nervous.
I made a room, so I'll send a code.
Hi!
I made a code.
I sent it to the chat room.
Let's go with this.
OK, I'm in.
Oh, wait.
Wait, what was it?
Where do I start?
Play, play and go online.
There is a code recording.
I see.
It's been a while, but I understand.
I don't understand at all.
I don't understand.
Do you want to look for a game?
Play.
Edgeworth.
Code.
Everyone is so cute.
Is that pizza?
Pizza?
It's taco.
Taco!
Tacos.
It looks delicious.
English or Japanese only?
Which one?
English?
Japanese?
English.
English?
OK.
Let's go with English only.
American English.
American English?
English.
American English.
English?
English.
Wait a minute.
English and English are prohibited?
I don't understand anything.
Whatever you are comfortable with.
The rules are...
When the game starts, turn off the mic.
When there is a meeting, turn on the mic.
All the rules are in the general voice chat.
But if there is a ghost, you can use the ghost voice chat.
I see.
From now on, we will use the general rules.
OK.
The general rules.
The rules for this one are normal among us, but just English only.
The language is English only.
English only.
Damn it!
I'm just a fellow crewmate.
Look at this thing.
What is it doing?
Oh my gosh.
I don't know how to play Among Us anymore.
Oh sorry.
My voice is kind of dead right now.
Hello everybody!
Pizza, pizza, pizza.
Welcome to Among Us.
Oh gosh.
I can't read it.
What the hell did I say?
Don't kill me.
Minto.
I'm Minto.
Mama is over there.
I'm kind of nervous because I've never collabed with a lot of these people.
That was fast.
So fast.
Fast.
What happened?
Who reported the body?
I did.
What happened?
When did you find...
I walked into electrical.
Oh yeah, I walked with you right?
We walked in together I think.
Where did you say it was?
Electrical.
Oh no.
Sounds so sus.
I'm innocent.
I don't do it.
This is too early to vote I think.
Let's have Shiki say her vision so we don't or will choose her as impostor.
We'll see.
What?
I didn't see anyone else on the left side.
Only in the middle or the right.
And the people I saw did not come from the left.
Ok, but I was with Shiki just now and she went to electrical in that short of a time.
I passed Ayami.
I'm navigator.
I'm too far.
I was also quite far in mid bay and I saw ETR there as well.
So I will back ETR up.
ETR safe?
Ayami safe?
I was at cafeteria.
Ok, Miri cafeteria.
I just arrived to the electrical the moment we got announcement.
So I was just like almost got into the electrical and then like...
Dead body something.
Not sus.
Skip?
Skip for not sus.
Good job.
It's ok, it's ok.
Bye bye guys.
Ok, ok.
She should probably say that sus means suspicious.
Cause she's like...
Where is mama going?
I know how this looks.
I know how it looks.
No, no, no, no.
I know how this looks.
I went to electrical to complete my tasks.
I did wires.
I did upload.
I mean, was it download or download?
But either way, I was in there with Pia.
And then I got off of the download and I looked to the right.
And Ayami is next to Pia's dead body.
No, no, no, no.
I was not thinking.
I'm innocent.
My click just slow because I'm 100 years old.
Don't forget.
I'm really pure this time.
Believe me.
I didn't see her going to electrical.
No, no, no.
I just want...
Please listen.
When I'm running to electronic...
Mint follow me.
We only two that time.
Mint so fast and run to me.
I'm scary and I'm running to my task.
No, I love you.
That's why I chase you.
No, no, no.
You hate me.
Don't block me.
You always block my discord.
Mint sauce this time.
Mint sauce.
I'm not bite the body.
I'm not, I'm not.
I'm not really...
I'm innocent.
This time really I'm innocent.
I'm chasing my cat.
This time I'm all-in using my cat.
Really, really pure this time.
99 seconds!
No, no, no.
You die!
Bye bye!
Mama sayonara.
I love you.
Where do I...I need to go to navigation.
Oh my God, Mama's little baby.
Mama's little baby.
Why are you flying?
I'm scared.
Oh, I thought it was over here.
I'll do wires real quick.
They'll handle it.
I believe.
See?
My sibling.
Maybe I should probably do my tasks.
I should probably...Mama's little baby.
Mama's little baby.
Wait, what the...
I was with Nana!
Oh no!
Yes!
We were together!
Oh no!
So...
We went to the reactor and then after I had a task with the electric.
And then just before going inside the electric I found the body.
It's always electric.
I can confirm I saw Nana Mona at the reactor, so I think that part of the story is definitely correct.
I saw Hinata-chan, Rururika-chan and Miss Milky at the reactor, so I think they're cool.
But I saw Koyo-chan coming from the electric.
I don't know, there was like...Koyo was kind of like running sussily earlier too.
What?
I was doing tasks and I was running to the reactor.
What is the feeling?
You can't...
Do you imagine going to the court and it's like, I have a feeling this person...
I have a feeling.
Why?
Because I have a feeling.
It's a great evidence.
I found the body at the same time as Mona.
Because they weren't there when I walked by.
Because I did tasks and then I was running to the reactor.
So it wasn't there.
Okay.
I was at storage, so nowhere near.
Maybe we should watch electrical a little bit, but then again, if we're saying that now, they might go somewhere else.
Because they weren't there when I ran by.
It's their favorite spot.
It's like make out point.
For dying.
I don't think I have any information enough to vote right now.
We have to be a little careful because I think we have a lot of people down.
It's two imposters?
It should be three.
That's a lot.
How many imposters are there?
There are three.
Three?
Three!
She's so scared!
She's so cute.
I'm cute as aggression against Nekomiya Hinata-san.
I'm watching.
I'll watch you too.
We watch each other.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm watching.
Oh,
I have to go to electrical!
Actually, I can go this way.
To reactor.
Cute aggression.
I've been watching Nekomiya Hinata for a very long time.
I haven't watched her in a bit, but I've known her for so long.
I'm kind of starstruck, you know.
She's a real OG.
First try.
Don't kill me, Shiki.
I thought Shiki was actually an imposter.
I can't trust anybody.
Can't trust a single soul.
What is this?
Wow, I went to electrical and I didn't die.
They're not really doing so much...
sabotage.
Oh!
I finished my tasks!
I'll go to the other side.
Unless... that's the imposter.
Unless...
I found both Nekomiya and Hinata by medbay.
Not next to it necessarily, but in the hallway near medbay.
Because, you know, there was like sabotage and then I ran that way, but...
I don't know.
I saw...
I saw... earlier I went to the navigation and I saw Hinata and Etora.
And then... I went right.
I saw Mio too, but that's it.
And then I ran away.
I saw Mio and I saw Etora and I saw...
Hinata and it was like...
Yeah, Mio there too in navigation and then separated.
So I don't know...
I just ran past someone and I don't know who it was.
One thing I will say...
Miori I ran past several times while I was on my own and I feel like would have had ample opportunity to kill me and didn't.
So I think I trust Miori.
I was at admin trying to fix oxygen.
I'm a good crewmate.
I'm done with my tasks.
I am too.
I'm almost done.
I have one left.
Yeah, I'm almost done too.
I live in security room.
I have one.
I think we have to vote somebody because we have...
Mint has been pretty quiet.
I don't know.
I know, I just said I'm done with my tasks.
I'm a good crewmate.
I was watching Mint on cameras and she had a few opportunities.
So maybe Mint and Mio are safe, maybe?
And Ettora-chan could say we dance together in front of the wires.
Too bad.
I know!
That's bad!
We got to vote!
Vote!
I don't know!
We're screwed!
We're so screwed.
I might call the emergency meeting just to guess.
Alright, I don't know.
I don't know.
We have to guess.
Koyo.
I hope somebody kills me.
Stack!
Stack kill!
Let's all get together and kill somebody...die!
It happened!
No way!
No!
Koyo!
Himahai-san saved me because I didn't kill Hinata or Ettora.
And I was like, oh shoot!
Because one of them came in and I was like, uh oh.
And then Himahai saved me.
I was tricked!
Sorry!
Ayame was okay?
Yeah, Ayame was okay.
Ayame was innocent.
I'm pure!
How did you do that?
How did you frame her?
I didn't even try framing.
I don't know how it happened.
It's just naturally...
Wait, I thought it was Shiki-san.
Because someone who killed me actually like... Shiki?
I think it's like...
Wait, weren't there three imposters?
Yeah, there were three.
Is three too much?
Maybe we should make it two.
There's 14 of us, so it's quite a lot.
I don't know three.
But three is like too fast!
Everyone is killing everybody!
Poyo-kun, serial killer.
Really scary.
I'm serial killer.
I didn't even hesitate to twist my neck.
Let's just make it three.
Three imposters.
Three first imposters.
This time, I'll only speak in Japanese.
I don't want to speak in Japanese!
I'm sorry, I don't understand.
Where is the other one?
Who?
Who didn't go back to their room?
There's one more person.
I'm scared of Japanese!
Bye bye!
Impossible.
This is impossible.
Wait!
This is so impossible.
No way!
I don't want to do it!
I'll try to kill.
Oh, it's here.
Where?
Hina-chan, where is this?
Under the toilet.
But...
No...
Aoi!
Aoi?
Yume Kaito was in the toilet.
Where was Yume Kaito?
In the toilet.
There were several people in the toilet.
Shiki was there, right?
When was I in the toilet?
I wonder if I was in the toilet.
Ayami and I were in the toilet, right?
So I went down from the toilet to the storage room.
And I found it.
But I think I passed by in the hallway.
I don't think so.
After the card was slashed, I was looking at the map to see where I was.
I went to the hallway, but I didn't go up or down.
I thought I was in the blue room, but I didn't go down.
So you were in the hallway and you saw me?
Yes.
I remember that there were three people passing by.
Maybe one of them was Ayami.
Yes.
I didn't go down, so I don't think anyone came from below.
The one who was close to me was...
I think so.
I think so too.
I think it's a little suspicious.
Let's do our best!
Guys, I'm not saying anything because...what do I need to say?
What do I need to say?
Otherwise, they'll be like...
They'll be like...
Also, I don't have confidence in my Japanese.
I have no confidence in my Japanese at all, baby.
So...
Electrical.
Good thing I didn't kill you.
Oh!
Mama!
Well...
We didn't pass by each other, but...
I don't think anything was different.
I was behind you.
Yes, I saw you behind me.
Yes.
I don't know the rest.
I don't know.
What I'm curious about is...
Didn't Ayami say she was going to meet you?
And then she was killed, right?
That's right.
Rikubo is suspicious.
Rikubo was in O2.
She was passing by me.
Also, was Miori there?
We passed by each other on the 5th floor.
Who was the one who fixed the reactor?
I was in the reactor.
Lulun, Himahai, and me.
The three of us were together for a long time.
I don't think I can kill you.
I was with Kahel once.
The four of us were safe.
What do you mean?
I don't know.
I uploaded it to the admin room.
After I uploaded it, I went through the stairs.
When I tried to go to the right, the door closed.
I was found at that moment.
Is Mint suspicious?
I wonder if it's possible to kill Ayami-san.
Don't go that far!
I love Mama.
There is no way I can kill her.
I didn't kill her.
There is no way I can kill her this time.
OK, electrical.
Maybe she wanted me to follow her.
Oh my god!
Mama's little baby!
Get Mama's little baby.
Mama's little baby.
I pretended.
I can't kill.
Right here.
We can double kill.
However many kill.
Let's double kill.
Double kill.
Kill!
Do you think they saw?
Oh shit!
I thought I was the wrong person.
Time to kill.
Kill!
I saw it!
Who?
I saw Mito-san coming out of the vent.
I saw Mito -san coming out of the vent.
I saw it.
It was light blue.
I was found out.
You were found out.
It looks so warm in there.
That's right.
Yes, it was me.
Everyone do your best!
Bye bye!
We can go to the ghost now.
Welcome!
3, 2, 1...
No yeah you!
How dare you!
I knew it!
Sorry!
How did you die?
Huh?
How did you die Koyo?
Bad girl!
Nunu ripped my neck off.
We were double kill.
Yeah, double kill.
Thanks!
Everytime I was like...
Ok, I trust this person.
They killed me the next second!
I do not trust anyone in this game.
Who is the other one?
Should I say?
Do you want me to say?
Yeah, we want to know.
It's Narin and Nanamona.
Ok.
I messed up.
You know, I personal know.
If I got into an impostor, I will kill you both.
Three of you, I will kill all of you.
Now we know what will happen when they die.
No, no, no!
I'm just joking!
Now we know.
No, I'm so sorry!
I don't think I'm gonna be an impostor soon.
I'm just a crewmate.
Yeah, I looked at the wrong color and I went out the vent and I said oops.
It's so funny.
It's an accident.
You got caught red-handed.
Everyone was like...
It's Mito!
Oopsie.
Everyone voted you out.
It's midnight for me.
I'm sleepy.
Oh really?
It's morning for me.
I'm sleepy.
It's morning.
It's actually not morning anymore.
It's like 11 in the morning.
I woke up early because I was scared I might wake up too late.
So I was like I have to wake up early before the collapse.
You're here.
You made it.
Let's see.
Mama.
Mito-chan.
I asked Ayami Mama.
Ayami Mama, do you like Oppai?
He said it.
And then I asked why Mito doesn't have Oppai.
Miori-chan?
Love all sizes.
Miori?
Miori-chan!
What happened?
It's over.
Me too.
Why Miori-chan?
I don't know.
You are too soft.
I want to look at the impostor.
What will they do?
I will look at someone.
Do you know who is the impostor?
Ruru and Nanamona.
Let's see.
Ruru is amazing.
Pro impostor.
That's right.
Very good.
How many impostors are left?
Kill!
We can win!
That's not anymore!
Do it!
No!
Do task!
I want to see Sloth!
Let's go!
I want to see the process of killing!
Kill!
Why are you killing?
I need bloodshed!
OK,
no one is left.
That's a good sign.
Let's go!
Do task!
Yes!
Please change!
5 seconds left.
A little more.
Oh is it?
It's very short.
The one with the longest voting time.
That's right.
Task...
Someone...
If we do a little more it will end.
I think it will end.
I have one left.
I did the task.
It's over.
Is the last one Koyo?
Koyo...
Let's do our best!
Please do your best!
Oh my god!
I have a good feeling.
One second guys, I'll change the...
The chat so that it is...
Since I'm in the ghost chat, I'll make a ghost chat and I'll make a live chat.
So give me one second.
Browser...
It's so quiet when we can't hear their voices.
I know right!
One second, one second.
I gotta get the same...
Me too, me too.
I want to know.
Someone voted on...
Do your best!
Purgatory is almost over.
One second.
Sorry guys.
Please, please, please.
Do your best!
Who is it?
There we go.
So that's...
It seems that Nanachi hasn't voted yet.
And the live.
I'll switch.
That should be suspicious enough.
It's the only one who hasn't voted yet!
I must have it.
No!
OK, I'll do my task.
Hopefully I'm the last one.
Wait, wait, wait.
Koyo, Koyo, I have an idea.
Don't do your task.
What?
Huh?
She's the impostor!
Why are you the impostor?
What are you doing?
I have an idea.
Kill, kill, kill!
Sorry, sorry, sorry!
Oh my gosh!
I think we should do the task.
I'm glad!
Wow!
Back to other chat.
When we gathered, when the door was closed, two impostors were split up.
It was really bad.
I couldn't do anything.
There were only impostors here.
Mint-chan, I'm sorry.
I should have done it when I found you, but I was surprised.
I made a mistake!
I'm so happy!
I understand!
Who was the impostor?
The impostor was Mint-san, and Luna-san, and Ruron-chan.
Mint-chan!
Mint-chan like broke my neck.
The moment I saw her I was like...
I don't know anything.
I'll make another game for Hide and Seek.
How to leave...
I have never played Hide and Seek.
It's fun!
I have never played it.
I have never played it either.
The rules are written in the middle, right?
Hide and Seek.
Hide and Seek is written here.
What?
Wow!
Maybe you should make a new room.
Sorry, I couldn't help myself.
This was so fast!
That was the room code, you guys.
Looper Egg.
Ok, ok.
Ok.
Why are you so fast?
Hide and Seek, Hide and Seek.
Oh my god, I'm so bad at that.
You have to restart the game.
So, we'll be split up into two teams.
Team Nihongo Japanese and Team English Eigo.
Nanamona speaks multiple languages, but I put you on Team Japanese because it fills the 7-7.
Nanamona is like, which one?
Which team?
So, Team Japanese language is Nanamona.
Hinata-san, Rurun-san, Ayami-san, Hikumu-san, Etra-san, and Shimahai-san.
Team English is Koyo, Mint, Milky, Pia, Miyo, Kaheru, and Shiki.
Oh my god.
The rule is...
It's ok.
The rule is split into two teams.
So, how this works is...
Because we cannot choose impostors, we'll restart the room.
Oh wait, no, I lied.
I'm reading the wrong rule.
That's for the other game if we have time.
Ok, wait, ok.
So, we'll do... so it's random.
So, hopefully we'll go to EN first or JP first and just enter EN or then JP.
But we'll work that out, so don't worry about that.
So, mic on the whole time.
So, during the game, mic on.
Also, you can give a hint to your teammates like...
Impostor...
The other team members are over there.
You can give a hint to that too.
So, if you see one and say like...
Oh, to help your team out, to find the person, you can be like...
Oh, this person is near somewhere that has...
Not say the room, but you can hint it.
Like, close, close.
Hot, cold, hot, cold.
That's good too.
So, this is...
So, first to two.
And then, one kill.
One kill is 0.5 points.
0.5 points.
Kill.
But...
If you kill your own team member...
Minus.
Minus 0.5 points.
You have to be careful.
I see, I see.
So, even if you find them, you can't kill them.
You have to be careful.
Wow, you have to be careful.
Japanese team...
I don't know.
It's a dark color.
If you...
Then, after the game, we'll check who completed their tasks.
And then...
The most completed task of like the members who complete all tasks.
We're not counting each individual tasks, but the member who completed all the tasks.
Then, we'll count that up and...
No...
Ah, I see.
I don't know how to explain that in Japanese, but...
Mona-chan, can you help with the one point?
So, actually, if it's all members, it'll be one point.
So, if all members complete all tasks, yeah.
That'd be everybody.
I'm scared.
Wait, which team?
So, what should we do now?
Should we do English only?
English only?
English only.
Only English?
Only English.
English only!
It's gonna be very scary.
I'm a little scared.
Alright, so that's A, B team and then Poster.
So, then B is A, B team.
Oh my gosh.
This is amazing.
Task, task.
That's fast.
What is this?
Oh, Kai.
Help me!
Task, task, task.
Alright.
Where are my...
I'm lost.
Where are...
I'm stuck.
What should I do?
It's too scary.
I don't like this.
No, no, no.
Oh my God.
What should I do?
What am I supposed to do?
I can't read.
I am illiterate.
Oh no.
Where is it?
No, no, no.
Someone is there.
Don't touch me.
Don't kill me.
Careful, guys.
For you.
For you, don't kill me.
Let's go that way.
Careful.
He's running.
Open up.
He got no one.
No one is inside.
What is this?
What should I do?
There is more.
Oh no, no, no.
Mito-chan!
Careful!
I don't like this.
Mito-chan!
Please don't do that.
What happened?
I don't like this.
I'm scared.
Again, again.
I don't like this.
Wrong member.
One more second.
I don't like this.
That was so scary.
How many did you kill?
How many points did you get?
How many?
The person who was killed...
Pia and Ayami-chan.
I...
Ayami...
I'm sorry.
Me too?
Me too.
So it was Ayami and...
Pia.
Miss you.
Thank you.
Why?
What happened?
Wait, I turned orange too.
Why?
I thought it was Kaheru.
Because it's orange.
I love red.
Kaheru is red.
Why?
Why did you change your color?
Wait a moment.
Let's add points.
How many?
Who?
How did you change?
It was an impostor.
Who was killed?
Ayami.
Ayami and Pia.
If only two people were killed, I would have killed them.
I see.
Ok, ok.
This one.
Your teammates?
I killed my teammates and enemies one by one.
How many points?
Zero points.
I see.
Ok,
next.
We got this.
We can win this.
If it's not in English, let's do it again.
So the killer for this one is not English.
Then we will reset it.
How is it gonna be?
Who is it?
I will do my best.
Reset it.
Ok.
Is it already dead?
Reset it.
Let's go back.
Ok.
I was killed.
She was killed.
I don't know if Misaki will survive or not, but...
Let's see how it goes.
The plan might change.
Thank you.
No problem.
I think we can only play one more game.
Yes.
Please do your best.
I'm sorry.
Are you ready?
I will make a new room.
Kill me.
I'm sorry.
Yeah!
Ok.
We are back to blue.
That's true.
That's amazing.
I went back to black earlier.
I don't remember if I was black or not.
I don't remember.
I was black.
I don't remember if I was black or not.
One more person.
If we have to restart the game, why don't we just let the impostor kill everyone so it ends?
You are right.
Let's kill her too.
Can someone... If someone like impostor don't kill me, I want to leave it just one time because I got killed.
Please don't kill me!
It's impossible!
Nice!
Nihongo!
I will do my task properly!
What is this?
I'm scared.
How do I find it?
Nihongo team's member Misato...
You can give hints to Miyo-chan.
Over here!
No, no, no, no, no.
There is no task.
Oh, Nanamona is...
What?
No, no, no, no.
Nanamona is not there.
Nanamona is...
What is this?
Where?
Nanamona is not bad.
I can't find it.
What is this?
What are you doing?
Where is this?
Who is this?
It's Koya-chan!
Koya-chan!
It's close.
Ah, this is it.
I don't like this.
Where?
It's close.
Again!
The task is over.
It's me!
Over here!
It's fast.
The task is over.
Ayame, you can do it!
Over here!
What is this?
Nanamona is...
Over here!
It's over!
Let's go!
Stop it!
It's over!
What are you doing?
Oh no!
Why?
Stop it!
Nice!
Isn't it good?
It's over.
Why?
Why did you kill me?
I'm sorry.
I thought we were friends!
Actually, it was too fast.
Ayame, Pia...
Ayame, Rikumu-san...
Ayame, Rikumu-san and...
Pia.
I give the Japanese language team 0 points...
and...
0.5!
We win!
Even though I died every time, it's ok!
We won!
The next game is...
Let's change the name.
The name?
How?
Let's make a new room...
Anything is ok?
I'll send it to you.
Where should we change the name?
In the game?
We can't do it without the Maya account.
We can change the name in the Maya account.
I see.
The list of names...
1, 2, 3, 4.
Ok.
The rule is a regular rule.
But, you have to just change your name...
and you can only refer people to their new name.
You can't be like...
Try not to use the color as the replacement for the name.
Just say the name.
Isn't the name that everyone has to change to in the chat?
So please check the chart.
Ok.
Oh no.
I change.
Let's change the name.
I see.
I made a mistake.
I finished the game.
I turned off the game.
I want to do this.
Why?
You.
Why you?
Don't use this name.
You.
You is hard.
Ok,
ok.
What does this mean?
You.
Thank you.
I see.
So you can just spell the name out.
You can say it like...
You, or like...
Or like, you know.
You.
You!
It's you.
You.
You!
Everyone is you.
Yeah!
Thank you.
I'm gonna join you.
Oh my god!
You and you and you and you and you.
You one.
You two.
Oh my god!
Who are you?
We are you.
We are all you.
So many.
It's you.
You...
It's you!
It's who?
Let's do it.
Bye bye.
Who said that?
Oh we are in a new place now.
I'm...
You...
One.
Everybody.
Now you can refer to me as my proper name.
You...
It's you.
Hey you!
Like you.
No, you.
Wait, where am I going?
I haven't played Among Us in so long you guys.
Wait, is it...
Here?
I thought...
Did they get rid of...
Having to get rid of the...
What's it called?
The...
You first had to always get rid of the...
What's it called first?
No?
The screws!
You!
Who did that?
So I saw you on cafeteria.
Only one body.
I came from medbay.
I went to the cafeteria.
And then I saw you!
You!
I'm here by locker room with you.
Oh...
I saw...
Who...
In cafeteria when...
They were with the body.
Wait, who?
Who?
In cafeteria...
How do you...
You!
Next to the body.
Who!
Not who, but who...
I saw.
Who?
Suspicious.
I see.
It's who...
Who did it?
Who?
Who is sus?
OK
Bye bye!
Let's see what we got.
Nothing over here.
I'm so used to being so fast and hide and seek.
I don't feel...I feel so slow now.
Guys, I'm trying so hard not to make a Metal Gear joke.
Everytime they are like...
Who?
Oh my gosh.
Such a lust for revenge.
It's so hard not to make a Metal Gear joke.
Oh, we are with...
You.
Please, nothing happens so that I can do my task.
Oh my gosh.
Too much.
We are with purple...no, we can't say the color.
Wait, which one is it?
This one?
I wasn't...I wasn't doing anything!
Where is this?
Decontamination.
Under.
Yes, under there.
Under decontamination and locker room.
I found it but...
Who are you with?
You.
It's not a small you, it's a big you.
You!
I was with you, but there was only two of us.
I was with you, but...
But...
You was dead.
But you was inside the laboratory.
I see.
I don't understand at all.
There are only three of us, so...
I was with three people, and I think those three are fine.
Who, you, and there was one more person, right?
Who, you, and you.
When there was a disturbance...
You and...
Who?
I think it's you.
You and you.
You didn't do anything.
I did it.
You?
We are definitely going to die.
No, I have just one more.
I have to go back to the reactor.
I have no idea what's going on.
I then added the Nihongo debuff.
It's too difficult.
Too muzukashii for me.
Too muzukashii for...
For me.
I got it.
Ok.
I did it!
Oh my God, it
was...
It's too strong.
Why?
Koya-chan, aren't there a lot of impostors?
Right?
It's not rigged.
You played this game too much, bro.
Rigged, rigged, rigged.
Rigged, rigged.
I sent you a new name, so I will send you a new game.
A new name.
What is this name?
Is it easy to play?
What is this?
It's easy, right?
Why my name is...
Amazing, my name is...
I think this one is good.
This one.
Hurry, hurry.
Cute.
I will send you too.
I will laugh.
Laugh, laugh, laugh.
I know, I know.
I can't do bad things.
Why?
I will send you too.
I know, I know.
Asukaru, Asukaru.
Let's go.
Good night, good night.
I'm just a little haha.
I want to shower heehee.
Heehee haha.
Heehoo.
Nothing here.
How do we go in?
Yay!
Mwahaha Ichi and Mwahaha regular both did it.
This one I gotta do.
Oh wait, I'm kinda bad at this.
Wait, oh here.
Nice.
Task completed.
Guys,
don't laugh.
Hahaha.
Where?
Adomi?
Was dead at Adomi.
I was at laboratory.
I was at reactor with Orororo.
Orororo I think is talking.
I was just at storage.
There was a point I was alone with Wara and they didn't kill me.
So I think Wara is OK.
Wara Wara is OK?
No, Wara is OK.
Someone was after me.
Who?
No, who was last game.
I was from admin and then I go to cafeteria.
Guys, I'm proud of that one.
But it was before the...
Who's dying?
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Anyone?
Any...
Arguments?
I don't see anyone.
I think I don't have enough information on Haha, Hiki, Ora Ora, Wara Wara, any of these.
I'm just Hihihaha.
Next time it could be Hi, it could be Kusai, it could be Wara Wara.
Wara Wara.
Bye bye!
OK guys, we gotta go to the balcony and we gotta do our little task here.
Begin to data...
Download...
Downloading ransomware onto the computer.
I'm gonna do this.
Complete 10 tasks.
Do you think someone else will get it?
Maybe not.
Oh gosh, everybody is up here.
Wait, wait.
Wait, we have 22 seconds until...
I'm gonna go look around and see if there is anyone dead.
This one is hard to use.
Oh my gosh.
Too many words.
Nakamita!
I saw someone.
I was doing the job in the top left.
Near the body but...
Because I don't see the screen.
But then when I go back, it's dead.
I saw...I saw...
I was like 3 people there but I don't know who.
Because I'm not familiar with the map so I opened the map so many times.
Oh my god.
What is this?
I saw...I saw...I saw a corpse.
Oh my god.
Wait a moment.
I heard...I saw...
I saw someone's head.
Wearing something.
I saw 3 people but...
In front of me...
A straw...
Died.
A straw?
A straw died.
I'm a little...
Who were the other two?
Futsan?
Futsan and Hehe.
That's suspicious.
Futsan and Futsan and Hehe.
Futsan!
Where is Futsan?
I saw a pink mask but...Hehe.
Futsan and Hehe?
Which one?
Hoho?
New member?
That's great!
Goodbye!
I'm done with tasks so I'm just gonna wander around.
Let's follow...
We'll go upstairs.
This is so strange especially because I played...
I played Henry Stickmin recently so all these sounds are so...
Now I'm thinking Henry Stickmin.
I played it just recently.
Oh my gosh, I'm doing...
I'm doing...
I'm watching.
I'm gonna make sure that she doesn't die.
If you could roll, lolo impostors.
Alright.
What if it's all three of them?
Don't stack you guys!
Where is she going?
It would be like sus if I followed her.
Do I look too much like a fangirl?
Am I fangirling too much?
Oh my gosh.
I found you.
Grass!
Grass?
I want to kill you.
Grass!
Which one?
Grass?
Grass!
Which one?
Not grass.
Grass!
OK Me?
Ola, Ola, Ola...
Very sus.
There was an emergency, but they didn't do it.
That's right.
Can someone translate that for me?
During the reactor meltdown Ola, Ola, Ola didn't do anything.
Because my name is so long to kill someone.
I cannot kill someone because my name is so big and long.
My name is too long.
I can see it.
Jack-san?
Grass.
The two people who killed me are the culprits.
Ha and Kusa are the culprits.
Ha and Kusa?
Who is not doing their...oh sorry.
Who is not doing their tasks?
Oh no, the meat.
Looks yummy though.
Mixed with pineapple.
I hope someone kills me right now.
Someone kill me.
I'm gonna go to a remote location.
I'm gonna wish for death.
Somebody kill me.
I'm wishing for death today.
I hope I die.
I hope I never see the light of day again.
Why is everybody here?
Comms?
What a strange thing to sabotage right now.
You're already dead though.
Maybe that's why I want to die again.
It's how I feel more comfortable.
Nice game!
I should have just...I should have just changed my name to Hetakuso instead of Kusa.
I thought actually...I know it's not Koyo-chan because nobody is dying.
You get a point!
Good point, good point.
Oh my god.
You can change your name if you want.
We'll just do a quick hide and seek.
Nobody is here.
I should have played this game before.
I should practice.
Koyo-chan!
How many hours did you play this game?
I really didn't play that much.
Really?
I'm going to check on your Steam profile.
I don't have the evidence.
What is my play hours?
Hold on, hold on.
I'm going to figure this out.
Let me get on Steam real quick.
Because you're so good in the game!
Oh my god, why is everybody dead?
I'm just aggressive because I play games where I beat people up.
I play Tekken.
Oh yeah, you kill people.
You have almost 20 hours in Among Us.
No, I have 15.7!
15.7, that's a huge difference.
That's like 25% more.
It says 19.2 hours on record.
No, it says 15!
It says 19.2.
Don't be so humble.
I only play like...
Is it?
Is it though?
Oh my god, I just hope...I don't have any expectations.
I just hope I'm not an impostor and I'm not dying.
How are you?
This map!
Oh my god.
What is this?
This map is so difficult!
This map...oh where am I?
How do you go here?
What is this?
I'll come back.
Wait, someone died right in front of me.
Ok.
No more scary!
Please don't die!
Scary, scary, scary.
I have a bad feeling about this.
Where is it?
It's over there.
I didn't do anything.
The tiger...
Nice ID.
Where is it?
What should I do with this?
Oh my god.
I'm so locked in.
Why so many?
How do I get there?
I can't get down.
There are so many!
I want to go to the toilet.
I really died.
Oh my god, a birdie.
Are you ok?
You can do it!
It's dangerous.
I saw it!
Stop it!
It's up.
Everyone is here.
What is this?
Stop it!
Everybody is here.
It's dangerous.
Let's die together.
Wait, wait, wait.
1...
Yay!
Everyone is running away.
It's dangerous.
It's too wide.
Where should I go?
It doesn't open at all.
I got lost.
I got lost too.
It was fun.
It was fun!
I want to take a picture.
What should I do?
Heart?
Let's make a heart!
Can you do it?
It's a good place.
I can see it.
But you can do it.
The coin on love is hidden.
We have like a gap here.
Yeah, there is a gap.
I can come over here.
Nice, nice, nice.
So cute!
Cheese!
Yay!
We did it!
Please take a picture later.
I will send it to you later.
Thank you!
Thank you everyone for participating.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you!
It was fun!
It was fun.
I apologize if I talk something that is not nice.
Thank you so much for the time and the fun.
It was such a blast.
Thank you so much for inviting me, Koya-chan.
Let's play again later sometime.
Of course!
Thank you!
Sorry for calling people sus.
You can call me sus anytime.
You're sus too.
I want to say thank you Miki Queen-chan-san for playing with me.
Probably because we will not have the chance again.
It was very fun.
Very fun collab.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much to Koya for organizing!
Thank you Koya!
Thank you for inviting me!
Thank you!
It was fun.
It was fun!
Let's play again sometime.
Let's play again!
Koya for the win!
Let's go from top to bottom.
You can say whatever you want.
Something short.
Any announcement you want.
And we just go from top to bottom.
Alright, I'll make this short.
First of all, thank you very much Koya-chan for inviting me.
Thank you for inviting me.
Today's collab was very fun.
I want to play again.
Thank you!
And another announcement.
I'll be having a maid cafe event on my birthday which is on May 4th.
So if you're interested, please do check it out.
Happy birthday maid cafe!
Let's go!
Thank you very much!
It was fun.
I have no announcement.
I had so much fun.
It was fun.
I want to touch Koya-chan's tail.
I want to pet Koya's tail.
I want to!
That's all.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much!
I have no announcement.
Please be careful of Koya's butt.
Please be careful.
That's all.
Thank you very much for opening the collab, Koya-chan!
Thank you so much for setting up the collab.
And everyone beware of Koya's butt.
Thank you!
It was so much fun.
Thank you so much to Koya for inviting me as well.
Announcements, I have a new cover out.
Yeah, that's about it.
But thank you so much, I had a lot of fun with everyone.
It was nice meeting you all.
Thank you!
I want to say thank you to Koya-chan for inviting me.
Even though I'm not officially EN's speaker.
And I don't also speak English that good.
But thank you so much for inviting me to the game.
Everyone here, it's my first time to have this big collaboration.
And I'm nervous.
I've never been in a big collab before.
And this is my first time.
So thank you so much.
And that was very, very fun.
I hope we can play sometime in the future.
And yeah, that's it.
Thank you so much.
And I have nothing, no announcements.
Yes, all good.
Thank you!
I don't really have any announcements.
But I just wanted to thank Koya.
Thank you so much for inviting me.
And everyone, thank you!
I had a lot of fun playing with you.
I can't speak!
I had a lot of fun!
Koya-chan, thank you.
And everyone, thank you.
Thank you everyone.
Please play again, I want.
And this year, I will participate in American events and German events.
Please look forward to it.
And...
And what else?
Nothing.
Thank you.
Next, I will practice playing tag.
I need practice playing tag.
I'm sorry!
Thank you!
It's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Thank you very much.
I'm really sorry I can't speak English.
The lobby is laughing!
It's okay, it's okay.
Then, let's say bye-bye in the lobby.
Bye-bye!
Please go ahead.
Please play again if you like.
Yes, please!
I have no announcement.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Thank you everybody for joining and for all your help.
And thank you Mona for translating on the spot and stuff for me.
Thank you so much.
I don't have any particular announcements, but I did upload some shorts.
I'll be uploading a few more dance shorts, so check them out.
You're so good!
You're good at dancing!
Amazing dance!
Really good!
Please do my collaboration again in the future.
I love you!
I want to do a collab with everyone.
Everyone is wonderful.
Let's play again.
Thank you everyone!
Thank you everybody for that time!
Thank you!
Shima-Ai-san, please go ahead.
It was so much fun!
Thank you so much for having such a wonderful party!
Let's play again!
Thank you!
Right now, I'm doing a collab with Fuji-Q Highland and Kemono Friends V Project.
It was so much fun!
We sold out the bus tour, but we're going to increase it.
We're going to increase it!
We're going to increase it, so please look forward to it!
That's all!
Thank you so much for inviting me today!
Big, big, big, big, big thank you to Koyo-chan and everyone!
Thank you everyone!
It was so much fun, and I'd be happy to play again.
I have an announcement!
Recently, a big box of 3D live goods will be on sale, so please take a look!
Thank you!
I finally got my 3D body, so if you...
Play with me, please!
Congratulations!
Thank you!
That's all!
Thank you so much!
I'm Rigm.
Thank you so much for today.
I'm not good at English, and I'm not good at Among Us, but I was able to do it with a smile thanks to these members.
Thank you so much!
It was fun!
Everyone was so cute!
I'm glad I met you all.
I heard your screams.
Yeah, I heard your screams.
There are two types of voices in the promotion.
We've started making reservations for the Blu-ray of the event, so if you're interested, please take a look at the commercials.
Thank you!
Please take a look!
Yes,
I'm Lululululika!
It was fun!
Thank you for inviting me!
It's been a while, but I had a great Sunday while listening to everyone's screams.
As an announcement, it's the same agency as Rigm, so it's Rigm's thing.
I'm not saying anything, but Rigm and Lulu have a member who's the same age as them.
The three of them have a new original song.
Congratulations!
It's being broadcast on the sub-channel, so please listen to it if you like.
Thank you very much!
It was
my first time playing tag, but it was really fun.
There's no announcement.
What was it again?
No suspense.
Announcement?
One more announcement.
Cute!
Let's collaborate again!
Welcome anytime!
Welcome!
Thank you very much!
Cute!
No cat!
No cat?
Brain...
Cute!
That's all.
Thank you!
It's time to say goodbye, so the three of us will say goodbye.
Yes.
Not bye-bye, but not sus.
Not sus?
Not sus.
We do 3, 2, 1 and say not sus.
Ready?
3, 2, 1...
Not sus!
Alright.
Bye-bye!
Is
it OK for me to answer you guys?
Like, at your Discord?
Yeah!
Please!
Thank you!
Yes, thank you so much.
OK, I deafened just in case.
I didn't know if they were streaming and if they were going to say something, you know.
Yay!
Thank you guys for...
It's a little bit short, but that's OK.
Short and sweet.
And I'm also so sleepy.
Thanks for another awesome stream and Olympic week, but texting wrong and posting the...
I'm OK!
I'll sleep!
Thank you for the ping!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you guys for a fun day, fun night.
Everybody was so cute.
Everybody was so sweet.
I will see you guys...
I just came!
I just came.
I'm sorry.
I want to sleep.
I'm sleepy.
I'm sleepy, so I'm going to bed.
My head turned white.
I'm sorry.
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I'm going to bed.
I'm going to dreamland.
What time is it now?
It's 1.30am.
Take it easy.
Thank you.
The reaction was funny.
Thank you!
Thank you.
I was really nervous, but it was funny and I'm glad.
Even if I don't have confidence in Japanese, I want to work harder and speak more.
If I can play with everyone again someday...
Okay, I'm done.
It's over.
Japanese is over.
Okay, thank you guys!
Have a good night!
Have a good day, have a good night!
And I'll see you guys when I see you next.
Bye bye!